libraries across the U.S are being
forced to pull thousands of books off
the shelves after many states and school
districts passed laws to restrict
children's access to books deemed too
sexual too violent or otherwise
inappropriate some of the books often
removed include genderqueer by Maya
kobabe The Bluest Eye by Toni Morrison
and the handmaid's tale by Margaret
Atwood who made a video with an
unburnable metal alloy copy of her book
when we have an effort to pick and
choose what can be taught in schools
what can be accessed by students what
kinds of identities we're trying to
learn about that is an affront to
democracy Utah recently passed a bill
allowing parents to challenge books they
want kept out of school libraries it's
basically erotic sexual contact so it's
it's pictures of people having sex it's
the graphic description or written words
of people having sex you would not be
able to distribute pornographic material
on the streets to a minor you would be
arrested but right now some of that
content is in school libraries Davis
County Utah's school system removed more
than 30 volumes after parent challenges
but then things got complicated an
anonymous parent filed a formal
complaint against a certain book they
said was chock full of sex and violence
and that book was the Bible the school
district removed eight Bibles from
elementary and Junior High School
libraries the move created an uproar
with Christian parents demonstrating in
protest the book Bill's author says the
challenge should have been dismissed
outright
somebody was trying to to poke the
legislature in the eye politically would
be my guess it was a hate-filled
ridiculous uh Challenge on its face the
challenges keep coming the latest cites
the Book of Mormon sacred to members of
the Latter-Day Saints Church who make up
60 percent of Utah's population
this week the County School Board
reversed the Bible restriction
a local book controversy resolved but a
nationwide debate that continues Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Salt Lake City Utah